everybody can go all right welcome
everybody to another hangout i recently
got asked to do an interview by
productivity expert Michael sliwinski
from Mike the Solinsky calm and he said
Evan I like to have you come on and do
an interview with me for my magazine in
for my podcast I thought hey why don't I
broadcast this too so that all you guys
can learn about productivity and get
introduced to Michael as well so Michael
welcome to the program and maybe just
give my audience a couple sentences
about who you are and why we're doing
this hey thanks for having me so my name
is michael i'm the founder and CEO of
nas being is a time and project
management application and apart from
doing the app we decided to do something
more to give content a really party
pretty content to people and we started
years ago proactive magazine and we
always try to feature people for
overachievers people who are just doing
lots of stuff and there is the other guy
here on the other side of my screen
who's an overachiever right now and and
we do an interview with these guys for
the practice magazine and feature them
and do the you know the the whole thing
and each issue of the magazine we fish
on the interview plus we have other
articles from other party BTW experts so
you can get inspired you know get
loved-up done especially you know get
your music new year's resolutions done
for 2050 cool well let's jump in okay so
this is the interview with Evan
Carmichael and and he's an entrepreneur
a very passionate entrepreneur and a
I've been falling heaven for for a long
time I'd always wanted to do an
interview with him so today we're having
him for the next issue of attractive
magazine so and now if you could tell us
something about yourself sure I'll of
entrepreneurs I believe in entrepreneurs
is my goal to help a billion
entrepreneurs uh I love seeing people
who are following their passion trying
to make the world a better place and
quick back story me i guess i started my
first business when i was 19 built it
sold it got into the venture capital
world a bit and then from there I was
doing speaking around the world helping
entrepreneurs is and now I have my
website which is I'm a chronicle com my
radio show youtube channel working on a
book deal basically all about helping
entrepreneurs you know I want to see you
turn your passion into a business that
can not only just support yourself your
family but also make the world a better
place yeah but you know for people I
mean especially I mean I'm from Europe
and especially in Europe you have this
very risk-averse so for people if they
have to choose between you know being a
lawyer or being you know a doctor you
know they're respectable you know
professions and then instead of that you
tell people to start companies and the
interpreters i right i I'm from Canada
uh my mother was born in tlie so I've
got I've got european blood in me um
yeah I'm not a great speaker to happen
at a corporate audience because I I said
yeah um but you know and this this
everybody has a degree of risk aversion
you know everybody is scared to launch a
company if you don't then you know there
may be something wrong with you two it's
natural to be nervous and scared and
there are always pressures that have put
on you it could be from yourself it
could be from your your culture society
could be your parents who expect you to
follow a certain path and you know my
advice is not just dump everything quit
at all go full-time put all your
retirement say
into this thing I prove it to yourself
start small make sure you love it make
sure you can start getting some results
it's okay to have your job and so your
business part-time but it's you know
there's something that's in the back of
your head that you have this idea that
you want to launch this company I'm of
the mindset that I don't want to live
with regret you know I'd rather know
that this business will work or won't
work and even that means going back and
getting the job after I'd rather know
that then be stuck in this corporate job
and live with regret for the rest of my
life yeah I think you know what people
are afraid of i think is just a little
bit what you what you just said is that
even if you have a good job it and but
you have this you know idea this is a
passionate about something so a
launching I mean starting something on
the side is actually it's viable right
you can really do it right absolutely uh
and i think you should i know there are
there are some entrepreneurs which I
guess you tell people you know you gotta
you gotta burn the boats you gotta just
go all in and I mean I guess that works
for some people but you know I am
totally okay with entrepreneurs starting
part time because really uh-huh running
a business is uh is a marathon it's a
long process and what happens oh this is
what often happens okay somebody wants
to start a business they say I hate my
job when I quit my job to walk into
their boss say I'm out of here not doing
this anymore gonna lunch my own business
they're all excited and they start their
business and they you know they're using
whatever savings they have and they last
for like three months or six months and
then they run out of money and they have
to go back and get another job and it's
way better to start hard time start
small start getting some results you
know start with half an hour a day but
do something every single day starting
some money and make sure that you know
when you quit your job you have some
kind of income stream coming in so that
you can last that you could latin might
take to build this business up yeah i
think i think you're totally spot-on you
know when i was starting my company no
sweet and what would happened was that i
was and i had like a batch
from conference so I had this badge and
I know the bed I wrote knows be CEO and
I was just a one-man show run watching
this and I would put the bat on at 4pm
so I'm to 4pm I was a consultant so I
was doing stuff for my you know from my
day and clients and then 4pm i would put
on the batch not not be CEO so I'm not
my intrapreneur so I'm not logic mind
you of my new app and and this is this
is how I email / worlds and then then
then make it happen cool I love it so
but but you know how about I mean how
you know usually or something saying
follow your passion and you know it's
it's something that you know this drive
that that we have in us but how do you
find this drive how do you tell you tell
people do you know how to find their
passion because people sometimes when i
say this i always say this as well just
like you know fully a passion like yeah
i know i don't know what my passion is
so i would you say to them uh the
biggest thing is to explore hmm try
stuff and see what you can lost in and
often you know the thing that that you
end up loving doing that that could end
up being a huge business for you often
is the thing that looks the works on
paper like if you thought logically
about it that you know you would never
go into that business because doesn't
make sense but but passion and love is
is nonsensical doesn't make sense and
here's a quick example you know when i
when i sold my first software company I
felt like yeah I'd lost child God you
know I wanted something else is a great
problem to have you know I had a great
exit but now I was like well what do I
do with my life what do I want to do and
and I was looking for another business
opportunity and one of the things I
started doing was actually taking salsa
classes and and you know if you look at
that on paper you'd say there's no way
every whatever get into the salsa
business you know there's no way that
that would make sense for me in that
business because I'm too tall you know I
take big steps I've never done any
dancing growing up I'm starting from
scratch you know I don't have the the
music
ality I don't speak Spanish and I'll
understand the muses like so many
logical reasons why there would be a
million other businesses for me to pick
the start but I went to the salsa class
and I went to a salsa club and I just I
just fell in love with it you know I
love the people I love the music I love
the feeling that I got there and and I
sucked at the start because I was
passionate about it I got better really
quickly and you know when you are
passionate about something you can
overcome any skill gap very quickly and
I ended up being investor in a business
that the largest salsa dancing school
probably in North America teaching five
six thousand people a year how to dance
uh and so you know I DJ there I still AM
dancing 20 hours a week I'll teach a
class there it is something that I love
to do and so if you don't know what your
passion is your best bet is to go and
start trying stuff just somebody invites
you to go do something try and see if
it's for you some things you'll find
that that you don't love and you know
that right away you know I want rock
climbing with the buddy of mine and and
I hated it you know the the the thing is
in my crotch and I'm afraid of high and
it's like I'm trying I'll try I'll go
once but I didn't like it so it's like
okay I can write that off I tried
snowboarding and snowboarding I was
obsessed with i loved it i would find
reasons to to push meeting so i can go
snowboarding it might say Michael I got
something I can't I can't do this today
and I'm on the snowboarding hill and
that passion lasted me for about a year
and a half and I still go snowboarding
I'm going this weekend i'll go like a
couple times a season but but my passion
fell off and then with salsa that's been
that's been over 10 years and I'm still
doing it so you'll find some things this
relates the business you'll find some
things that you try that that you hate
and you know and that's great you'll
find something that you love for a
little bit and then you go all in and
then it fades and and it's okay to to
move on you should move on if you're not
crashing about something anymore you
shouldn't stick to it and then you'll
find something that you follow love with
that you
want to spend all your time in it that
that makes you come alive that's where
you want to spend your time and if you
you may know what your audience you know
listening reading the magazine they may
know it already but if you don't then
then just start to explore say yes to
things so you're not going to find your
passion just doing the same things that
you're doing right now you gotta step
outside you got to say yes you got
explore you got to take some risks and
get to know yourself a little better I
think I think cuz you know I have two
children so one of the things that
somebody also gave me a very good advice
about raising children was too stupid
curiosity in them so that they have very
well as curious they always trying new
things to note that there is cute I
think this is what we've been you know a
little bit you know pushed by the school
system not to be curious not to ask
questions not to go explore right ah
yeah I mean we can go into a hole in
your book okay worms but yeah I mean I
have a five-year-old son and and I agree
like you want you want people to be
curious you should be curious its
children are naturally curious and
somewhere along the line we lose and
consume the clothes and and its opening
that back up and you know we are not
meant to live inside a box anyway and
only you can get yourself out of that
box you know that you're your family
society your friends your your workplace
wants to keep you there and only you can
get out and and it's going to come from
starting to do things are a little bit
different that you may not have done
before but you want to explore yourself
and learn a little more mm-hmm okay so
let's switch inevitable is the subject
so and obviously you are a very busy
person so if you can you know this we
don't all right magazines about
proactivity so how do you how do you get
stuff done I mean how do you have any do
you have any routine and I think that
you know the cops to stay on track and
because even if you know even if your
fashionable stuff they're always you
know worst days their days where you
know you cannot get the rhythm or
something so how do you know if you have
any any any way the United tricks that
did help you you know say stay active
state you know keep going yeah this
there's a lot that I can share
talking about routine and this is really
important assess for entrepreneurs
because man it's hard being an
entrepreneur and you could be on top of
the world one day you know you go to
some conference or event or you you
watch video you're reading the book and
you're all excited like yeah I'm gonna
this is this is what I'm gonna do I'm so
excited and so energized and you're
working hard you come with great ideas
and then the next day you wake up and
it's like where did that energy go and
it's starting from track like so often
it happens so many entrepreneurs or even
worse you get you know that energy may
give you some bold idea to say here's
what I'm gonna do like I'm finally gonna
go and do this I'm filing a break out of
my fear my comfort zone I'm gonna do
this this is finally that this is the
day finally and then you sleep on it and
the next day you wake up when you look
at that idea like that was such a stupid
idea who am I to do that I can't do that
there's no way and you lose the courage
um so I find that instead of instead of
just having that those be accidents
where maybe I happen to watch it that
video interview or maybe I happen to
read that book I like to design my day
so that in the morning I'm set up for
energy and for success and so I have a I
have a fairly strict routine that I try
to do every day that really helps set me
up um some of it may seem uh fluffy or
stupid or whatever but um so the first
thing I do when I wake up I won't share
it I'm happy to share the first thing
I'll do when I wake up is I have this
notepad next to me um and I write down
three things that I'm grateful for and
some of them are logical easy things you
might think my wife my son you know my
family my health some of them it's
whatever i'm thinking of so it could be
ah the internet i'm grateful for the
internet i'm grateful to me you know i
don't know it sounds silly but um it
takes me two minutes i write down three
things every morning and it just kind of
gets me set up for a positive
environment um the next thing i'll do is
my my wife is usually out of the house
before even get up she works early and
so i'll send her
quick message on on facebook a little
heart or a little funny cartoon
character or whatever and again it's a
it's just set in the day up with love
and positivity that's kind of what i
want to introduce into my life every
more so like really super quick easy
things um the next thing I do now this
becomes more more serious I'll go to my
computer and I'll put on some music and
I have a point list that i call my
belief playlist and you know everybody
can have their own list and it's
basically songs that make me want to
move song said when i listen to i'm
doing this got the head going one of
then gonna shake something right uh you
know it's so easy to be sluggish and
slow in the morning and i find like when
you're moving and when you're energetic
when you're happy you're much more
likely to follow through and have a
great day so I make a list of things of
songs that that I want to sing too and
dance do and I play it randomly there's
maybe 80 songs on there so they come up
randomly and and it's just a great way
to start the day um other little things
I'll start with my breakfast which is
lentils every morning sometimes with
chickpeas sometimes of the spinach just
for some energy and a huge glass of
lemon water because you wake up d high
grade these are little things but you
wake up so dehydrated that the best
thing to fill yourself with in the
morning isn't a cup of coffee it's a
huge glass of water um and put some
lemon in there as well there's a whole
bunch of benefits you can look it up
it's co-signed it but it helps me next
this is ice happens every day this is a
serious okay okay okay is really good
okay but I don't have that all happens
really quickly it takes me longer to
explain it than actually do it um next I
start with my big why my little why and
the big why is that what it what am I
trying to do I'm trying to help a
billion entrepreneurs you know remind
yourself of what your big goal is to
stay motivated what is that big thing
that you want to accomplish either right
end of the year or by the end of next
year or your lifetime goal so that's my
big wine it should be something that
motivates you and then the little wise
are the
things that can inspire you on a daily
basis so for me it's my youtube videos
my youtube audience is awesome they
leave comments every single day and and
their comments like Evan that video you
may change my life thank you so much for
making it so always very uplifting
positive things and I'm sure you get you
get them to from your magazine meters
and your podcast listeners uh and so
reminding me that that there's people
who are really valuing what I'm doing
use me energy gets me motivated makes me
want to get up and go and do it again
and again and again it's easy for me now
because because I have a large YouTube
audience but I've done this for years
when I was first getting started I would
go and do presentations and seminars and
and would leave us such a high you know
like you leave your presentation I don't
know if you do public speaking but you
leave a session and people are just
clamping and telling you how helpful you
were and it's such a good high and then
the next day you wake up and it's over
you gotta like this woman's up high what
happened um and so I would make a
powerpoint file that I looked at every
morning just in the comments that people
left for me either told me face-to-face
or emailed me later and I would just
remind myself that the work that I'm
doing is important um and so I find that
that really helps set me up for a super
productive day and and that happens that
happens every single day yeah I really
believe that you should design your life
on purpose and instead of letting life
kind of throw things at you and always
been in reactive mode instead of
practically finding what you do yeah
when I was um when I was starting with
with with with my obligation with with
productivity and I actually learned this
just what you just said from from a
friend of mine who was cause laughing at
me because he observed my morning if he
saw that I'm rig just accounts right in
the morning it because we were on a
business trip to Europe so to see how I
work in the morning and he said Michael
is not you know this is not the way to
work I think this is not because if you
go like this no wonder that the whole
day you're like with your tongue outside
just trying to catch whatever is you
know getting getting to you so you have
to start yourself you have to start a as
i said on purpose right yeah and i'm a
big believer in running and no crisis
business I don't respond emergencies I I
prefer to build a business where there
are no emergencies or I have my team
manage it I don't use a cell phone
because I don't want people to call me
that's the problem you have a cell phone
people call you and some other people's
agenda for your time so I use one of the
notes samsung phones and i have a just
used Wi-Fi i have no phone number of no
data package because i don't want
somebody interrupting my day you know
it's a minor interruption has a huge
impact if you're working on something
that's important and somebody calls you
even if you don't pick it up you just
look at who it is you look at your phone
that's a huge distraction that then it's
hard for you to jump back into what
you're doing before now if you actually
answer the phone and and talk to the
person then forget about whatever
project you're working on so you've got
to stay focused and so um I run a no
crisis business I don't answer phones
I'm not fast on email I i set up chunks
of time that helped me plan my calendar
accordingly so today's thursday i don't
know when it's gonna come out on your
podcast but for me it's thursday right
now I do all of my um my public facing
stuff on Thursday my radio shows on
Thursday my interviews are Thursday my
meetings are Thursday my phone calls or
thursday everything this morning I had
two meetings at a local starbucks I came
here I had an interview with you I've
got three more meetings this afternoon
and another meeting later tonight
Thursday is my public facing day and I
find it's great because I wake up you
know I i know i'm going to be meeting
people that's all i'm doing today you
know I shave i put on my t-shirt I'm
ready to go every day of the week is
something different monday is my work in
the business important project
kind of admin stuff set up my stuff for
the weekday so all the projects all the
emails that have to get back feel it's
all done on a monday but i know i'm not
meeting anybody so I could you know I
don't have to shave you know I don't
have to wear the bridge here whatever
right and it's just a different mindset
because if you're like yeah I'm not a
naturally extroverted person um and I
can switch easily between like focus you
know leave me alone let me do my work to
then uh you know I gotta talk to people
and I gotta be outgoing and on those
mondays like I don't want to talk to
anybody just let me focus let me do my
thing and then I don't want to have to
jump to a meeting and then come back and
then jump to me and then come back um
and so monday is my monday tuesday is my
writing day and writing the book all day
I'm basically just writing you you want
you email me you're not going to get a
response anytime soon wednesday i do
videos you know wednesday my youtube
channel is something i love deeply
passionate about I spent an entire day
basic thing studio recording what videos
on Wednesday and then Thursday is my
meeting day and so you know chunking is
super important anything that you do
multiple times per day do once per day
multiple times per week the once per
week I'm sure you know you've talked
about something similar have guests on
the talked about jumping um but that's
how I do it and i find it dramatically
improves my my productivity i mean this
is this is this is Goldman this is this
exactly a help help help people should
work out in my big mentor and and and a
fellow blogger Michael Hayek's he was
always talking about about chunking and
well the fact that he always meets jump
on Fridays so it's just like you have a
Thursday he has on Fridays so I knew
that if I wanted to talk to him I could
email him you know I we should chat
about this or that or whatever so I knew
that I'm gonna talk to him at one of the
fridays so it sounds going to be like
you know now or already know tomorrow
it's gonna be this friday or next friday
or you know in five weeks friday but
it's gonna be a friday because he's
always works like that and i think this
is what people are missing here that
that in this information society that we
have right now with so many things
coming in
the focus is our main currency right now
is this is I think right yeah you know I
and for people who are thinking about
chunking the most common reason for not
to do it that people come up with is I
might miss an opportunity right and and
what you have to be willing to do is
miss small opportunities to go for big
ones you know if you want to achieve
something big could work on important
projects you have to be willing to miss
smaller opportunities and and here's an
example so you know I miss a lot of
media stuff reporters will call me or
well they can't call me they have a you
know just have my phone number that goes
I have a phone number just goes right to
voicemail the leave messages um
reporters would email me or they'll
tweet me and I miss it I miss it all the
time um because i'm doing my videos and
i can't get interrupted you know i'm
doing this interview with you i can't
get interrupted by a reporter and so i
will miss some of those opportunities
but i know that the project i'm working
on a are bigger than that and they have
to be up to value your time right you
can't afford to be interrupted because
you're working on something that's
really important um now you know if
Oprah calls me and says hey Evan I want
you to come down in Chicago on Thursday
yeah okay I'll go I'll put off my book
writing for a week and I'll go see Oprah
you know there will be opportunities
that will make you miss your schedule a
little bit but that doesn't happen that
often it's really more about you getting
over the fact that you're able to miss
out on small opportunities to go for big
ones because so many people are just
reaching for these emergencies and the
small opportunities that they never do
anything big yeah i think so and then
especially okay simply when you I mean
the very good example you're writing a
book so if you're missing some small
operation Tuesday it doesn't matter it's
you're working on something really big
and as you can tell us a little more
about it well it's gonna be about having
them to finish it up visit right yeah
the book the book is I'm really excited
about the book um I've been kind of
keeping under wraps not seeing too much
but but I have a business philosophy
that everybody has one word that they
that they stand for one word that
defines them and your
chance at business success is to
understand what that is and then bring
it to your company and build it around
your one word and that makes it easy to
make decisions that makes it easy to
bring on a team it makes it easy for
people to talk about you because most
businesses are boring and don't stand
for anything but the entrepreneur's
themselves do they just don't bring that
to their company so that's what the book
is about I'm interviewing people like
Jessica Alba who started a business
around honest that's her one word yeah
Billy coldness I have an interview
tomorrow that I think will be live on my
channel with the guy named dheeraj who
built the business around empathy it's a
two billion dollar company and so people
are using these strategies and I'm
writing kind of the guidebook on how to
do it those exciting so well I'm yeah so
one word one word yeah mine is believe
you probably know that being a follower
exactly but it is firing the one word
finding your one word to bring it to
your business we're getting some
questions on youtube I don't know if you
want to go to take yes that's this
letter okay so mohsen wrote in to say
Evan how do you stay focused on creating
the product and raise capital for the
product you created um you know
screening bottoms is is you go to making
time for you got a chunk of the time in
your calendar for any big thing that you
want to do and you know Mike I don't
know how you do this but any any big
project that I'm working on I make it a
priority and set up time and my calendar
to do it I like to work in 90 minute
chunks with a 15-minute break in between
so 90 minute fifteen ninety minute 15 I
finally after 90 minutes my brain starts
to get a little fried if you're really
focused for 90 minutes um you know for
me my brain starts to lose focus a
little but after that and I know I got
to get something done within 90 minutes
so it focuses me to work really hard on
it um and so what I would do if that's
your question is you're trying to figure
how do i create my product how do I
raise capital for a sign one or two or
three time slots every single week
that's 90 minutes long that says during
this time I'm working on my product or
during this time I'm
I'm raising capital I'm not answering
email I'm not checking Facebook I'm not
picking up phone calls and not checking
news not doing anything else that's not
related to that specific task and if
you'd set outside that time on a regular
basis you'll find you make massive
progress towards achieving your goal
yeah I think your answer there chunky
mean this way it would be just perfect
because they are two totally different
activities I mean you know Billy product
and doing a venture capital this is you
know so different unrelated that really
thinks that you have to end so I think
would be great idea yeah yeah jumping
between them is crazy this is what most
entrepreneurs do they do a little bit
here a little bit here a little bit here
like you're thinking your pitch deck for
VC it's going to require totally
different thinking then what you're
going to put in your next product and so
focus your time I like the hour and a
half the only exception i find is when
when i'm in flow and i think we've all
experienced flow as always you know when
you're you're working and and you put
your head down it's 99 in the morning
and you look up and it's six o'clock and
I you like what what just happened and
lo doesn't happen all that often you
know flow is not happening every single
day for you and your business and you
know when when I find myself in flow I
actually will change my schedule around
to try to stay there as long as possible
because when you're in flow the goal
that comes out of it is amazing what you
create is fantastic um you don't want to
trick yourself you know I'm traverse
we're smart we come up with really smart
fool ourselves brother ha I mean flow
answering these emails you know I gotta
keep right that's that's BS does not
flow is low do feel flow then I think I
try to stay in that as long as possible
and I will push things off so I can get
that can stay there but that's how I'm
not in flow every day not even close so
I try to do 90 minute chunks with 15
minutes in between I'm using more of
this bubble daughter technique so 25
minutes five minute break 45 minutes but
and I thought what I
found out is that exactly when if i
start with 25 minutes you know by the
clock and the clocks says stop and I
feel like I'm going I feel like I'm
thought maybe not this slow but it's I'm
getting into the flow I don't do the
break I just continue and and and then
put the fight time I put 25 more and
just keep going so this is why yeah I
like I mean whatever technique works I
think you got to make it work for you um
I don't think there's one strategy for
everybody you know the Pomodoro for me I
just find the 25 minutes too short um if
I'm it takes me a couple minutes to get
into whatever I'm doing and my ticket
and then so then I only have you know by
a 15 minutes just to do it then I find
like for me it's not enough time maybe I
think too much I don't know me I i wish
i could work it doesn't work for me but
anyways good good fair another question
elisa one little book be out since i'm
starting to listen to you and applying
what you say my sales have actually
started increasing alright thank you my
question is what can i do to create a
larger audience on YouTube um I don't
know my god I love that fits your
audience like I can answer that
separately afterwards if you want no it
can get some dip so you know everyone
else gotta listen to it um so the book I
don't know when that's going to be on
I'm working on it it's me I need to I
need to spend I don't know I got to be
really comfortable with it I'm working
to finding the right publisher and for
YouTube audience I guess you know kinda
it relates to this topic to and time
management um be consistent so many
people say honest i have this goal i'm
going to be on youtube i'm going to have
an awesome channel and then they post
every every week for a month and then
they stopped right and this is common
with any goal and i'm going to be a
blogger this year I'm gonna do XYZ this
year and you go hardcore go to the gym
this year you go hardcore and then you
stopped because it's too much you got to
be consistent it's much better to just
like building your product you like a
lot time with your week to focus on it
for me youtube is such an important part
of my schedule that I do two things one
in the morning I talked to my routine I
look at my comments every day right
every day I look at my comment
respond to every comment that I get
pretty much on YouTube that's crazy um
most people don't do that and it's not
going to be scalable at some point I
won't be able to do it but it's it like
it feeds my soul I loved it and then
recording the videos I leave I leave a
whole day Wednesday is just video day
that's it and you know if you want to
make youtube really important then you
need to dedicate a huge chunk of time to
going out and making the videos my
videos have gained traction because I've
got a lot better but I have 1500 +
videos you know look back to my first
videos I sucked I had 0 comments you
know I didn't have a lot of thumbs up I
didn't have a lot of momentum and by
practicing and getting better and and
following something I was passionate
about in a logging time and being
consistent every day on my channel
there's two videos coming out every
single day two videos hit my youtube
channel you got to be consistent and to
do that we gotta plan your day I know
we're bumping up against the clock
Michael reserve one forgetting one sad
yeah I just wanted to ask you no good
about your goals for this year but I
know it's the book but is there anything
else that you wanna you know get this
year uh my personal goal is actually a
fun / selfish one where I'm at an agency
I have an agent in New York represents
me who puts me um you know the into
deals he's helping with a book deal for
example and I'm the number two youtuber
um at at the agency and so my goal this
year has become the number one at the
agency so it's a moving target I wish I
could say like I need to have X number
of subscribers because as I grow she
grows too so I gotta grow faster yeah so
that's my goal I guess check in check in
at the end of the year we'll see how
we're doing okay okay pretty pretty
great okay perfect so I mean from my end
it's perfect thank you very much for for
you know for for for for having me and
for fergie known for being for the
infographic magazine I've been really
amazing advice go to buy gold advice
because really really dumb
attendance and if somebody doesn't
believe you look you up and see you know
what we go to accomplish so you know you
live by that is just me quick cool well
I gotta hop on a phone call but Michael
thank you so much for the time and let
me know when the podcast comes out the
magazine comes out and I'll share with
my okay thank you very much I lied you
know I her checkup okay okay